in the growing list by the way of
politicians and actors accused of sexual
assault and inappropriate touching
former Republican President George HW
Bush the father of George W Bush is now
being accused by six women of having
groped them and the latest is Rosalind
Corrigan who was only 16 years old
at the time of the alleged incident Bush
was 79 at the time in 20 in 2003 this
reportedly took place in Texas when she
was being photographed standing next to
the then former president seven
different people have corroborated that
this is the exact story that Corrigan
told them immediately after the alleged
incident there are five other women who
have made similar claims in recent weeks
and the allegations are very similar
every single time which is Bush grabbed
them by the buttocks it started with one
incident which was written off as some
kind of avuncular joke and avuncular you
know the funk Euler literally means
being of or like an uncle but it's
actually pretty creepy in this case to
say that it was just him being avuncular
we can also maybe write part of this off
too you know advanced age or some kind
of subclinical dementia or something
like that but it's going beyond that
with these mounting allegations this is
coming from people in different walks of
life of different ages and the
explanation from the bush camp is sort
of an affirmative defense the bush camp
has said he does pat women's rear but he
sees it as sort of just a good-natured
thing that he does and he apologizes to
anyone who might have been offended by
that touching is this different because
Bush is older ninety three years old I
don't know I mean it's not really
different because he's older but
certainly it's true that if he never did
this stuff before age 79 and it seems to
have taken place almost exclusively
between 79 and 93 we know about this
being sort of common behavior at nursing
homes this hyper sexuality that
sometimes happens in people with again
not necessarily diagnosed dementia but
subclinical right some low baseline
level of dementia that is very common in
people as
age the the hyper sexual nursing home
residents stuff is an issue that's often
dealt with and I keep coming back to if
it doesn't really seem that people care
about this as a collective they're
really not going to care about a few
incidents from George HW Bush you do get
outraged individuals when you hear
stories like this and most people say
this is bad it's not desirable but by
and large if as a society we cared that
much about men in power doing this stuff
President Donald J Trump would not be
President Donald J Trump right and we
can say well this person suffered the
consequences Kevin Spacey Bill Cosby who
else who else has suffered the
consequences of this stuff there's many
of them but at the bottom line if
President Donald Trump became president
despite the fact that he admitted to
doing this type of stuff despite the
fact that he had an accuser as young as
13 years old say that he raped her it is
really vile that this is going on in so
many different places Bush admitted it
and made it seem like these are friendly
Pat's on the butt but how can we really
think that society is going to take this
seriously when we have President Donald
Trump despite more than a dozen
allegations of sexual assault and
unwanted sexual conduct send me your
thoughts what do you think what if
anything can be done about this david
pakman.com slash read it is where almost
5,000 of our viewers and listeners are
discussing this and many other topics
from today's show join us there we'll
take a break and be back after this
today's program is made possible in part
by nerd kung fu dot-com as many of you
know I'm a huge sci-fi fan big fan of
the author arthur c clarke and I got my
2001 a Space Odyssey t-shirt on today
which I got from nerd kung fu com
it's the one website for all of my show
movie comic book and humor needs nerd
kung fu dot-com is over 70,000 shirts
they've got hoodies tank tops polo
shirts long-sleeve shirts and men's
women's kids they even have infant sizes
all the way down to 6 month and all the
way up to 6 XL for their adult
sizes all their products are officially
licensed with hundreds of genres from
Deadpool and Star Trek to American
Horror Story and Star Wars to choose
from you can check out the selection at
nerd kung fu com get free shipping on
all US orders over 75 bucks plus you can
support our show and save more when you
use the coupon code pakman 101 for 10%
off of your first order that is nerd
kung fu comm coupon code pakman 101
check it out